- I had so much fun with all of you today,
what a great way to go into the weekend.
And you our virtual
family and friends, VFFs
thank you so much you guys.
(audience clapping)
Listen, I always talk to
everybody after the show,
and so I just wanted to
share a little sentiment
that we like to tell everyone,
which is that I want you to know how much
it means to me that you're here, okay?
We are so grateful, for the fact
that you choose to spend time with us.
I know that you could be watching
or doing a million other things,
and the fact that you choose
to spend it here with us,
and really set the stage
for us all coming together
and building this community
from all over the country
and other countries too sometimes,
you have no idea how important this is,
and how much you elevate the show
with your energy and presence,
both in that energy and
the way this wall looks,
this wall reminds me of
a photo album every time
and it makes me emotional, so thank you
because you make this show better.
(audience clapping)
And if you wanna be one of
our VFF and come join us,
then visit the drewbarrymoreshow.com
to reserve tickets,
and you can also connect with us
on Twitter at DrewBarrymoreTV,
and on Facebook and Instagram
at the drewbarrymoreshow.
All right you guys, thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)